[Music]
yeah please all right Christopher you
can keep this in people see a little
behind the scenes they get excited
I see he's gonna take over also I'm not
sure what type of music you want I could
give you some some music uh but it might
be cool if you do like a hip-hop maybe
black and white if you could like do
this [ __ ] we could do it in digital but
yeah that's cool
um and then I think it might be good if
I I don't know what's going on but I
trust that it's all going to come
together yes
hey folks here we are where your world
might be drunk what's shaking I thought
we had a guest today what the hell where
is he
[Music]
what are you painting the house here
that's a hell of an outfit there oh hey
what's up man uh oh [ __ ] are we able to
do that I didn't know I thought you
weren't into the handshaking
okay okay
shakes for bits microphone
the OCD leaves you for comedy sake truly
truly it's um so I stopped doing
stand-up for a couple years during
the Holocaust yeah
and uh I started back up again in
January
and I was always wiping the mics and I
it made me talk about OCD which I didn't
want to and one day I decided I'm just
gonna do it and I grabbed the mic
and I was just like I'm fine I'm still
you know difficult yeah but it bits
[ __ ] oh they flowing in
bits over
emotional obsessive responses good for
you yeah let your creative guy let the
juices fly in your germaphobe well don't
say that to my ex-wife or you could say
it's uh wait a minute I don't know what
to do it again I'm gonna walk in
now we have a good time we have a good
time it's fun this outfit is very 90s I
think the 90s are coming back my ladies
dressing 90. well he he had a push for
white man can't jump I think you should
have been cast as the Woody Harrelson
appreciate that in a white man what are
you kidding he can hoop dude really
we'll cut to a clip
foreign
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
my bad okay have you guys hope we had
together with my next been bad but I'll
be ready for you dude ready for me well
if we hope it has to be ready for me
on the team the same team here drunk
versus shoes off this is this is a
league he'll take me he'll take me
easily you think oh yeah dude come on
Manhattan night uh yeah b-baller you
don't take me we've never met outside of
a podcast so we only know each other on
camera so you may think this is me being
hyperbolic okay I am so good at
basketball really that it's that you'd
be like why did you pick comedy and it's
gonna be corny maybe I shouldn't say it
all right said no maybe you know what
I'm not sure
wow that's beautiful well white man
can't jump is basketball and
entertainment coming together oh I was
rooting for him we were together when
you told me you were up for the part uh
well auditioning I don't know if I was
up for it that's the point but at this
time yeah now Blake uh even told me
friends of Blake Griffin and he told me
that if people won't believe that I
can't dunk so it does doesn't make sense
what are you six three today yeah I'm
sick three I cannot come close to Duncan
really no hmm no hops yeah I'm below the
rim I'm like a Zebo you know you could
touch the rim yeah yeah okay I Could
Touch the I can get the net yeah oh yeah
level the Boost that's good you should
put that on your on on reels for sure do
you guys wear shorts or reels what do
you think is better than careers I'm
short uh I'm both I have both good take
one of those shoes they used to make
pull these up man straight yeah the
strange shoes I had them the ones that
you you put on they were like this tall
yes oh they helped you jump my boots
there's one there's I think they're
called strange shoes that I used where
the it's a regular shoe but then there's
this big thing just on the toe off the
heel yeah it forces you to stay off the
heels yeah yeah it was right there the
the white and blue but that's it those
ones yeah no I was thinking of something
else they're like a whole thing they're
crazy are you talking about shoes to
make you taller no they help you're
supposed to walk around and they just
help you jump
oh yeah that was good you got a killer
calf I don't I don't know if it's
because of that or just getting older
but I use those senior of high school
couldn't dunk use them for a few months
started dunking wow that's not a
necessarily because of this yeah but
Duncan Trussell
County picked over you the guy they
picked over you for uh White Men Can't
Jump I don't think you can really play
you know what I don't like to speak
poorly about other people but I'm gonna
be honest I don't think he's much of a
player is that Marlo who's Jack Marlow
are you a dad I I don't know sorry I
don't know the hip uh the hip white
rappers these days yeah Harlow he's a
cute cute kid cute guy but pull him up
playing he looks like uh admit the form
is off what's the actor who you know
he's uh Jon Snow the brother the king
kit Carrington no but the other one the
one that that dies at the Red Wedding
spoiler alert sorry oh he kind of looks
like a um
a musician version of that guy okay well
he's a musician that's well there you go
I see the whole world what about Woody
was Woody decent for what he could do
really it looked pretty good here's the
thing that Woody could do and not to say
anybody can is this the kid yeah okay
look at the form though I don't know
he's like doing this what is this
interesting
unbelievable has pardon my French
unbelievable Charisma he's fun he's
lovable I don't know much about Jack
Marlow but I will say are you sure
that's what I'm reading on the Jersey I
know foreign
so I have a work thing in a couple hours
I did take a little bit of an edible
that'll be kicking in soon okay porn I
just call it porn but yes there's a lot
it's mostly men okay well this will this
will help you I also think it's
important to acknowledge that that
people we call it this fetish [ __ ] or
gay porn or black porn or jew porn it's
just it's just no one is watching no
one's watching it that's that search has
never been entered once
that's actually
oh that sucks that's what that sucks
but I'm not trying I don't want to I
don't want to be known as a Jewish
pornographic actor actually an actor
who's beautiful yeah all right do you do
you identify as a Jew yeah do you like
that as an identifier yeah why not did
you choose it no it chose me Rick
Glassman
he's chosen people yeah yeah you're
you're a big peeb
I'm I mean I can't get away from it not
that I'd want to I truly I don't want to
yeah but I'll tell you what I don't love
I I do this thank you
but what about the you always hear
nebuchi short balding you guys are the
exact opposite of The Stereotype we're
tall three of the same you got full
heads of hair and you're uh not that
never I mean you got the germaphobe in
the neck but what's the neck you're not
a bad neck yeah you knew that yeah by
the neck sounds like a physical
attribute but I get it I got some I got
some arthritis all around ah okay yeah
we're getting my surgery here here and
here whoa triple hernia elbow and
shoulder and boy are my arms tired we'll
be right back what happened you lifted a
couch I had a uh even I gotta tell you
something even though I'm Jewish I'm so
athletic that my hernias are even
athletic because it wasn't the
intestines it's actually called and look
it up a sports hernia oh yeah I had
sport if I'm gonna have a hernia Let It
Be Sports yeah and while they were there
they did the the belly button the belly
button yeah were you an Audi well if I
was or a different kind of car I like
that they get I like that they get
specific with the uh ailments now yeah
yeah Sports it's like that's a towel STD
what STD towel yeah yeah
there's a tennis elbow there's athlete's
foot
like those are the big ones yeah
Achilles heel that's just a body part
there's a lower back
a knee uh-huh yeah well there's no
bowling yeah there's the bowling finger
I have it oh yeah
should we cut to a clip sure can you
bowl very good Are you seriously William
he's a Midwestern kid that's right I
used to bowl a lot not So Much Anymore
arms are tired but I do have a cool uh I
almost build a perfect game I did first
10 strikes first 10 rolls were strikes I
was two away from perfect that's pretty
damn good so that's I mean you basically
did the perfect game and you couldn't
you couldn't get the last yeah no you
know when you get that close it makes it
a little bit harder but it taught me a
lesson maybe I shouldn't say maybe it's
corny
[ __ ] come on glassy when you chase
Perfection you're only going to be
disappointed but when you're grateful
for what you've accomplished and who you
are in that moment hell I'm a 288 I'm
damn proud of it
I mean that's my ex's weight
is that why did you break up with her
because she's so heavy well she died oh
I'm so sorry well the wheelchair got
caught and fell down the stairs we got
caught on what I flip broomstick in the
spoke at the whole wait a minute wait a
minute you killed her well I was
cleaning
I was sweeping up I fell she I dropped
the broom it went in the spoke she went
down the stairs if this were on my
podcast I would pitch to you we filmed
this and we got to a clip all right we
get an actor to play Norman we dramatize
it yeah he plays the girl in the
wheelchair though yeah but Jack Harlow
will be me you know these I re-watched
white man can't jump the original so
great so good very very good uh Wesley
Snipes is amazing he's magnetic magnetic
yeah magnetic what does magnanimous mean
is it racist thinking that then there's
magnesium right that's not racist
magnesium is a I think if you call a
black guy magnetic
because of because you know all the
X-Men like yeah he's always been white
yes because he's repelling against the
race although now they're trying to say
he's repelling Against Racism huh yeah
it's metal where are you getting racism
no no because he's the only X-Men that
has never been characterized as black as
every other Incarnation has been a black
Wolverine has been a black everything I
think they're hesitant to cast the
villains black sometimes can I say
something look at the Joker if you if
you look at Magneto as a villain it's
because you're not understanding
oppression
well he's white he's a mutant and he's a
holocaust Survivor I don't care for that
term sorry he's a mutant who was a
concentration camp Survivor got it and
uh man those Nazis must have felt pretty
dumb when they when they got Magneto in
there that's a show I would like to see
by the way Magneto during the Holocaust
uh while he was because he was still a
kid he didn't understand his powers yet
right do you know this that he was he
was I didn't know that yeah he's still
survivor he's a Survivor I didn't know
that yeah he's a Survivor which is what
makes things a little complicated and uh
in the universe now because he ages yet
now he would be you know 100 years old
almost right so it's a little confusing
because his storyline is yeah he was uh
he was a holocaust where I was a child
there but much like black mutant don't
crack
all right I'm just saying you know you
got these uh these mutants they can they
can heal themselves and shoot fire and
all this why would they age right some
of them do uh okay I would a lot of
people would call you a mutant with your
amazing ability to go up on stage and
tell people you know what you do that I
like you tell it how it is yeah try to
keep it real up there you know I don't
want to let the people down hey we got a
good shape what are you making for us
today there so today is my version of
our most famous cocktail the paper plane
yeah
um this is our biggest you know that
drink oh this is like our biggest hit
cocktail so people love it you choose
them you you curate this
one has like specific flavors yeah
um but uh this is my version of it it's
a little lighter because instead of uh
Amar no nino I use this thing called
italicus which is like a clear Amaro
it's very delicious and very good for
like a hot day as well Amaro Stoudemire
and italicus sounds like a Jewish scroll
or something sounds like rock rock music
to me nothing else matters metallicus
so how do you are we picking up Audi we
got a good room mic in here you could
hear all that he's got a mic on his uh
apron you guys yeah and the chest tears
killing it you got a good swoop going
yeah you do I gotta get a haircut it's
too hot again as soon as I leave the
house the Flop works I have a question I
used Campari once instead of aperol it
didn't work it's a little too bitter uh
rolls a little bit sweeter on the side
so
um and especially if you're using a
Morrow already you already have some
bitter notes there
so but this stuff is actually delicious
it's made from Bergamot oranges so it
has this like really light uh flavor but
it still kind of has that like depth of
Amaro flavor so it's super interesting
we should say for the folks at home it's
about 9 000 degrees in New York City I
mean Dan's sweating like a Jew at an
audit but uh I'm glad you're here and I
hate this heat it's brutal magnanimous
is generous or forgiving especially
toward a rival or less powerful person I
would argue in fact I'm going to so I'm
gonna I'll move that away so it doesn't
peek Magneto is not magnanimous right
he's not generous and he definitely
ain't forgiving not to not to the weaker
human race yes yes good point that's
kind of like a big you know big comic
when they're nice to the open mikers
he's magnanimous you know I was watching
you guys that think it was a Stavros
were you talking about how now that
you're more successful and experienced
you can understand not being the most
um connected to your feature or opening
act because you're working and it's
tiring yeah we try to bring our own
friends right so it's too much work
sometimes meeting a new guy or gal and
getting to know
of a show you need when you're on the
road as much as we are you kind of have
to yeah it helps to and also helps to
show when you know
I care about the whole show a lot of the
time the person they book is terrific
but it's a gamble
played by a black man once really yeah
well Damon Wayans Jr from the Bayou
really I'm pitching it
when we first met on my podcast the
first one we did I told you about I have
at the time I think I said 40 or 45
minutes of funny in me a day yeah and
like a controlled one exactly and you're
saying well just like a runner you gotta
practice that and work up to get more
you should have an unlimited amount and
I think this is kind of the point that
what you're saying is when you're
talking to people in a green room before
a show or something it's not that you
can't be funny but I do I do believe
that energy is finite and as you do it
your your energy meter goes down a
little and you only have so much right
that's why the meet and greet is so hard
because it just sucks the energy it's
way harder than a show because you gotta
go hello get out of here you don't get
the one guy who decides to grab your
stomach here for the picture like all
right dude yeah the ass grab you get the
headlock guy you get the spit on you guy
yes now we're just I'm just thinking
like I'm gonna get a cold I'm gonna get
sick yeah there's so many spit people
that didn't realize how gross things
were until covet I've always thought
that blowing out a birthday candle was
gross it was a big big thing thanks for
joining us Rick yeah
just have a sip it's pretty light you're
not gonna It's Not Gonna Get You old
it's not gonna [ __ ] you up dude I mean
you took an edible before a table read
is that what you're doing whoa really oh
this is delicious best drink paper plane
I don't know what to call this one yet
because it's a lighter version of the
paper plane I was thinking like the
model airplane or something like that
the Wright brothers the right brother
there you go what about Comfort plus
well it's a lesser version
economy paper plane
it's a very expensive version it's just
like okay
this is so good dude we needed this
class I can't wait till we do first
class till we get Bodega cat or whiskey
we get RTD those little cans yeah those
ready to drink we need to do a paper
plan yeah no problem here here yeah
cockpit that's good
do you ever do sets where you don't have
a drink yeah
yeah you know in the city I'm not really
drinking but on the road I'll I'll I
don't drink before but I'll have one
during that's my weird literally like
you'll bring it your first one drink up
on stage yep does one drink do anything
for you no but it you know it gets the
wheels moving I guess what is the wheels
moving is it a a a sense of ease or is
it a sense of silliness it's more of a
mental thing of like your brain's going
oh where this is familiar we have like
one cup of coffee does it really do a
lot if you're a major coffee drinker it
kind of it gets it going gets it going
did you grease in the pan before the uh
the eggs what do you use to grease a pan
I go butter
yeah you did the spray I thought you
were a Pam guy no come on Pam get out of
here that's our publicist but uh no I go
butter we have the same person who does
our publicity stuff and she's such a New
Yorker yeah yeah like I was on the phone
with her the other day and she's just
she's like I want you to do this I want
you to do that then she goes ah [ __ ] and
I was like what she's like a bird [ __ ]
on me anyway I went it doesn't even
break conversation just keeps going
that's a pretty good bird [ __ ] she's so
New York you know they say a bird
[ __ ] on you is good luck I've heard
that and I think I think that's just a
really it's almost like a a small
version of the origins of religion I
feel like where like here's something
that maybe scares you or is not good but
if we could I guess professionally we
call it a spin yeah right but like you
know I know you're unhappy but a bird
[ __ ] on you is going to bring you
great wealth it's like you know what
a great wealth better than bird [ __ ]
right
you might be a redneck or however again
well get her done but I think oh sorry I
think 80 of everything we talk about
tradition is religion and the other 20
is nautical
hear me out
so you go uh Hey God Goodbye Is God be
with you just shortened over the years
so that's religious but then you got
stuff like oh I'm gonna break the ice
which comes from Ships coming in
Breaking the eye the cargo ships would
break ice to get to the shore right so
that's I think nautical is big do you
think there's anything about being like
being Captain being this type of alpha
energy somebody who is good at breaking
the ice in conversation it's kind of
leading steering the conversation maybe
steering too starboard bow you got the
big circle I actually heard that
everything is 80 which I also heard
religion
um 15 percent
uh nautical and 30 physical
oh wow Little Giants yeah good pull ice
box you know you said Oh Captain I'm
thinking of that what's that Robin
Williams and we did Poet Society great
movie oh it's [ __ ] so cheesy you like
it I love it it's so [ __ ] corny as a
troubled youth and a a guy who needed
some guidance I loved I went to Catholic
school I don't remember it oh it's
classic it's it's cheap it's definitely
schmaltzy it's very Huggy doggy and the
the kid shoots himself spoiler alert but
uh but reading poems in a cave by
firelight and that's how you seduce
girls in ice I mean that's what I tried
to do oh it kind of worked it worked
yeah so we learned what to do with girls
from what we watched I was an American
Pie baby so I would go to the library to
learn how to eat a girl's [ __ ] oh yeah
I tried that too all those movies always
have the older brother who just knew how
to eat [ __ ] older brothers never talk
to my brother about eating [ __ ] open
like Greg he's like here's what you do
he's like I'm gay there's a book under
my bed
that you wrote a book about eating
muffins yeah isn't it just alphabet with
the type that's all I learned I did I I
didn't kiss uh until I was 17 and I was
too scared to kiss I recently started
talking about this on stage and I get
insecure if I say something that I'm
doing as a bit in conversation so I feel
like I have to just acknowledge that
right we do lots of bits on here uh this
isn't a bit though I'm gonna less bit it
okay uh
I bought a book because I didn't know if
I was supposed to how to kiss I didn't
know if it was supposed to do top lip on
top lip and bottom lip on bottom lip or
you stagger the lips and I was a little
late to like be asking because everyone
else is already getting sucked and
[ __ ] and stuff yeah so I bought a book
but it wasn't about kissing it was Kim
Cattrall's book on how to eat snatch she
wrote a book on that oh yeah she really
leaned in huh yeah good for her yeah and
then I heard she had a divorce because
her ex-husband wanted to [ __ ] her too
much what that can't be the reason pull
it up pull it up I'm a Rex
but Jesus I mean she had Porky she
wasn't she was the chicken porkies who
is just like ah Ah that's your whole
character the same yeah exactly it's
[ __ ] she's a very sexual woman believe
me sexual yeah well I read her book on
how to eat [ __ ] cost me my marriage sex
the city divorce Mark Levinson schedule
meant she was never home wait a minute
that's a little different yeah that's
not what it is she's a sexy lady yeah I
don't know this is a kind of a taboo
thing but I think all women are
beautiful
uh that's I hope they don't clip that I
want to get in trouble here Caitlyn
Jenner she's Brave and beautiful okay
are you doing Brave
when you're throwing braids when you're
a public figure and and and you finally
have the courage to stand up for
yourself as opposed to worry about the
shame that is projected from society's
standards and just go out and do what
makes you happy listen if you're not
stepping on anyone else's toes or dick
or [ __ ] yeah you don't do what you want
and I think can we get a picture up of
her I think she's so she's very
attractive very brave caitly very brave
good for you empowering very brave man
this is this is an inspirational episode
yeah well she hates uh Sarah Jessica
Parr Oh I thought we were talking about
uh the the other girl huh weren't we
talking about uh control I thought we
were talking about Caitlyn Jenner oh
sorry
yeah yeah sorry there's too many women I
can't keep track but yeah tell me about
it but Kim control
your boy had some [ __ ] spices are you
Jewish this morning I know I was gonna
say we need a spot guys get on board
give us a little sponsorship Pepto I
should have brought you so I have these
peppermint pills that are made that's
not sustainable oh yeah it is I've been
going this hard for yeah but that's
because you keep needing that oh can I
tell you something that a lot of people
don't realize about stomach acid you got
the time pushing on me
when people think they want to get rid
of their stomach acid because that's
what's causing the reflex and coming up
but the truth is when you have food it
needs to be submerged under the acid
when you get rid of the acid what
happens is the food is sitting on top
and not digesting and it's going to make
it worse and worse and worse don't get
rid of the acid Peppers you're saying I
just that was a cop about what I just
thought I'm saying this is what your
practice and now here we are and I'm
offering you a piece of Intel that you
use as you'd like but so how does he
wean off of it peppermint pills
can we take a note of that peppermint
pills I had some spicy diarrhea and I
will say I was on the toilet I forgot I
had a cleaning lady come because you
know I forgot she was coming she came
like a little early so I thought someone
was breaking into my apartment so I ran
off the toilet pants down like ah what
were you gonna do if it was somebody
breaking in I don't know I didn't think
that far ahead I just had to act this
[ __ ] all over them
well I just had to act and I ran out and
I went ah and she goes hi I'm like man
I'm so not scary I tried to make myself
big like it was a bear and I was like ah
and she was
it was down on the butt side oh did you
have to shower uh I did shower right
after yeah because did it get a little
that was all right if you when you fart
in a little comes out shirt do you
consider [ __ ] your pants if it you
have to if it's all over your butt but
it doesn't get in the Underpants
yes
you got it you really gotta let the
water go down and you look as you get
older the water going down that butt
crack it starts to feel nicer and nice
oh it's the best and I've been wiping I
gotta get a bidet because oh they're
they're a necessity to me I've been
wiping and getting some some pink hard
to install Pink as in no as in my
favorite color uh blood yes because
you're wiping too hard yes and too often
do you poop a lot but I want to clean a
[ __ ] gerbil right here I haven't
pooped since I've last seen you to be
honest wow too much acid
breaking it all up listen I think it's
anxiety I take magnesium incidentally at
night that helps me poop helps you sleep
too I take a certain kind of magnesium
it's kind of like a cleanse it's called
mago7 we'll put it up on the screen uh
you're a Maga guy
when it comes to my bowels yeah Krav
Maga talk about a piece of [ __ ] hey I
don't have a point of view on that all
right it's hard to stay on one topic
with you because you're you're all over
the buried uh he buried Ivana on his
golf course at the first hole because he
got a tax break ah I guess one of the
funniest [ __ ] isn't that true I heard
that you don't have to pay taxes if it's
uh a golf course or if it's a she's
right by the first business which is
also what he called her but uh no she's
right by the that's amazing wow what a
move yeah that's hilarious
is it like a lump in the grass you have
to get over like a putt-putt or it's
just like her mouth to go through to get
to the hole like those clown teeth yeah
there's a windmill in front of her mouth
but we should respect that sure how did
she go staircase fell they're making a
13-part documentary on it it was an owl
what's it called uh the stairs would you
name it I would call it uh don't stare
good uh
um we I would call it uh uh Alcoholics
Anonymous with an extra step hey 12
steps
there's some talk about was it you know
did she get pushed who knows but also
like it's very possible at that age to
be looking at your phone sure and just
the slip yeah we'll never know we'll
never know would you tell me how much
you agree with this statement it's none
of our business what about stare not
well
all right all right we're up too late
stairwell staring out well no I love it
all right keep I cut you off there no
straight you didn't you had something
this is our most Jewish Happy Head yeah
I know right I feel so gooey we should
have gotten a little lock spread for you
man I feel like yeah oh that would have
been the sweet yeah we should next time
do you practice
yeah Judaism yeah no uh I mean I guess
probably the same as you just it's kind
of religious yeah but we still practice
you're taking Pepto-Bismol yeah but I'm
gonna wean off after what you just said
yeah but even even the way you get off
is Jewish it's yeah wean is a very
Jewish way until I get off Viewpoint I
gotta send you a link send me a link
yeah please I've been doing it and I'm
not even joking on my patreon I've been
posting it not my face but I've been
posting uh
I mean porn is getting blown and stuff
on my patreon what really actually like
the pro if you want to see me getting my
dick sucked go to patreon.com take your
shoes off is there a Sizzle
um I guess I could send you something
you could put it in uh I'll have it
blurred okay perfect yeah I've been
doing porn
do Asian people blur their points I
think in Japan yeah really is it Japan
or China I think it's Japan but that's
why they're so repressed
because they don't they don't get it out
with the porn well porn has only been
mainstreaming accessible the way it has
for the past 10 some years that's not
enough time to build a resentment for
suppression is there oh yeah we were I
think we were suppressed in the 80s
pretty bad because we used to jack off
to when we were oh my God it was just
cleavage sure whatever Buffy the Vampire
Slayer I think about what they're
jerking off to now hit me baby one more
time it was the first music video
yeah dude three months ago ooh drive me
crazy no no no just hit me baby just hit
me baby yeah I didn't feel great after
masturbating to it yeah oops I Did It
Again I yeah yeah I felt like
I just felt like I was I was doing too
much to get to this thing I had to put a
tape in I had to record it it was too
much and if I'm gonna do a VHS
masturbating
I I honestly I was masturbating before I
knew it was sexual I used to put when I
was eight or so pre-cum pre-covet as
well I would put my um
self
yeah uh under the you know before a
shower you have the the best part but
then there's the part where every shower
is a little different how do you why is
it coming out of here yeah yeah you
gotta find a knob I used to have it
coming out of here the shower part and I
would kind of like go up next to it and
I would take my [ __ ]
and I would put it under the water in
and sometimes it would take five minutes
sometimes it would take like a half hour
and I didn't know what it was I just
know if you leave it there long enough
it'll feel good I didn't know it was
sexual whoa and I remember I did it and
and after I I would want to go in and
I'm like just keep doing it it feels so
good yeah but every time I would finish
I would not want to do it anymore I
remember one time I was gonna do I'm
like Rick you're not going to want to do
it a second time but I'm telling you now
you're going to want to do it so do it
twice and I quit and that turns out it's
kind of like you know when you have an
orgasm sometimes it takes some time yeah
yeah I have a question when you heard
the Britney Spears songs on the radio
did he get excited no question although
I did like her music and I did buy while
we're on the subject of Japanese porn I
did buy uh her album the Japanese
version because it came with a special
insert that had more pictures damn you
see we had no porn you had to get uh
creative Victoria's Secret catalogs big
yeah that's what's so sorry who were you
like oh I'm sorry well I was talking
about a Jewish pod no I'm sorry I'm so
sorry great Josh gottleman Joe you know
you got the Irish goodbye when you leave
without saying goodbye Jewish goodbyes
would you say goodbye to everyone so
long that they leave
his joke but uh it's that's what's crazy
about like a Pete Davidson now a
comedian [ __ ] all these hot women
celebrity women because that wasn't
happening when we were coming up
I I forgot why this is related we were
talking about what we were jerk off to
oh yes Cindy Crawford yeah Cindy
Crawford was your gal oh yeah well if
she was a Victoria's Secret gal and then
Pete Davidson banged her daughter
so I used to I once got a Playboy and my
mom had a laminating machine I'm getting
the silent treatment what do you mean
from God she's a woman it's a woman oh
yeah no it's very good I'm so sorry no
no no I threw it in too late I was I was
a little sore slow I was on bubble bath
[ __ ] and you say it again do it again
now it's over it's over I think God is a
woman yeah I'm getting the silent
treatment
I don't get it all right well I
appreciate that
that's what you were saying there I
eliminated his Playboy this these
pictures is Playboy and uh I would you
laminated I laminated it when no one was
home in my parents bathroom so you could
just clean off the semen well because I
wanted to bring it in the shower because
the only way I knew to feel that way
this is when I started this is pre-cum
and pre-covet still but it was sexual at
this point you were resourceful I know
what a shirt laminated that's adorable
well you wanted to bring it in the
bubble bath you take that to Hobby Lobby
how do you gotta lay my mom had as a
lamination machine she does crafts all
the time to make I don't know what she
would eliminate pictures now this is
before frames and you masturbate like a
50 year old woman you're in the tub
about scrapbooking over here
you shut the [ __ ] up
that's funny because I used to print out
naked women photos print them out like
that whole thing using all the ink
sounds like a bad psycho impression
and uh and then I would fold them up put
in my pocket I remember I was mowing the
lawn one time literally mowing the lawn
it was a hot summer day I was probably
like 11 mowing the lawn and I'd be like
huh
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I remember my friend had a had
a color printer and we would print a
bunch of porn from the internet and we
just stapled it together and called it
play Amigo we use like a graphic and we
sold it for five bucks a copy whoa and
we got busted by our gay homeroom
teacher uh he was like 70. he was
awesome he didn't give a [ __ ] he just
thought he goes I'll just tell them you
were selling lingerie magazines out of
trouble what a good name what's his name
we'll put his Instagram handle up here
died Mr Johnson
[Music]
um
to sell a Dragon Ball Z uh vcds I would
born burn the series hey you didn't kiss
till you were 18 huh
okay keep going there four eyes
Seventeen sorry um good magazine uh
yeah just I remember selling stuff yeah
you're just you know being resourceful
we would have a little make our little
businesses and now we're podcast Kings
yeah
yeah selling mattresses now we're
selling whiskey do you guys have whiskey
sponsors this is our whiskey wait a
minute this is your brand of whiskey oh
yeah I didn't know you guys had a pardon
me for Vega cats spirits.com we're
trying to retire on this puppy like
Clooney you know I've never I've never
smelt a whiskey that I like I'm sorry so
uh you know the one this is a very
nerve-wracking moment here well I'm not
gonna like it I'm just curious if it
makes me borrow I feel like we shouldn't
have them smell it no no no
that's a resident whiskey it's a rye
are you kidding me no I would drink the
whole bottle
for in a in any type of glass this is so
good that and it feels so smooth here
here wow thank you that's like a that's
like a shower drain right there yeah
it's great yeah good stuff what about
that big mop you got there that's gonna
take a while to dry
um that's why I carry a hat with me aha
I like to get when my hair is wet I put
a hat on and when it dries in the Hat it
keeps My Curls ah there's a little trick
I found out yeah as also a curly haired
douche I don't like to uh wash my hair a
lot you don't like to wash it or even
wet it either or
um because once you get it the way you
like it once you wet it or shampoo it or
whatever it's over how much do you spend
on a haircut
too much how much is too much 50. really
if you were complaining about your
haircut I I we both were complaining we
didn't like our haircuts we just I think
that looks you look squawked some stuff
yeah dude I I got a haircut the woman
was panicking I paid two it was like a
30 haircut she she was it her first
haircut it felt like it was her first
haircut she was panicking with the uh
with the blade she was like I was like
you're making me nervous yeah you're
nervous you don't feel comfortable
asking her to stop
once once you're once you're halfway
through you got to just it's like sex
you gotta finish I have a question for
you you finish no if you're getting a
massage and you're paying for this
massage and it's not a it's there's just
not hard enough or they're doing weird
spot do you just sit there and take it
or do you let them know do you give them
a little Direction one time I had to
leave because she was she didn't know
what she was doing really she was so bad
that I was like you're gonna injure me
what how would like elbows and [ __ ] just
like in the on like my bone I'm like you
don't know what you're doing whoa see
I'm so dumb I would have thought maybe
I'm an idiot maybe it's supposed to feel
like well it was really painful wow good
for you for leaving I felt that way once
I gave a lot of trust to Netflix I
remember back when you would rate stuff
with five stars I remember I was about
to rate something three stars and I saw
Netflix suggested I would like it four
stars and I thought maybe I did like it
more yeah that's where they got rid of
the rating it was causing Jews too much
stress but I just got a haircut the guy
hated me and he was [ __ ] with me on
purpose I go I hate you well here's why
it closed at seven I got there at about
6 15 and I walk in and went cling cling
and I went
old Italian guy and I was like too late
too late he goes all right sit down and
he whipped the chair like hard with the
towel or whatever I don't think that's
because he's angry he was probably
getting the hair off the chair he was
angry I mean it was coming out of his
house dude he was he was Italian yeah he
still is yeah and uh I sat down he
whipped the the Smock on me all quick
and he goes how do you want the
sideburns like I like it right here and
he did it up here how long ago this is
two days ago which figure is diapers are
great no I like it down here but he
chopped an extra inch off just to spite
me and then he goes he goes how do you
want the back and I go rounded he did
the square he did he did damn yeah so he
was screwing me even the guy next to me
was sweeping up like oh boy you pissed
off uh Vesuvio or whatever and Vesuvio
that's the name of the restaurant in uh
[ __ ] Sopranos oh is that right yeah
volcano but uh well that's Vesuvius yeah
all right but yeah so uh and then I said
a little this little that he just did
everything wrong wrong and I would say
uh can you do this and he wouldn't
answer and I'll go excuse me can you do
this and you go yeah so he was [ __ ]
with me and I almost walked but I didn't
and I still tipped him yeah I always tip
well no matter she did a bad job and she
the second she's done I was like oh and
she goes I'm sorry she admitted she
[ __ ] up I
I don't
I would have liked him she was like you
look great you're crazy oh okay I would
prefer that I like it I'm sorry I like
when you ever at a restaurant and all
the food comes up and it's missing
something and then they say oh the
kitchen's whatever but you know they
just forgot to put it in yeah I've had
I've had waiters uh uh say to me
I forgot I'm sorry
I'm tipping more yes I love it they're
human I do like honesty but not with
when it's when you're like it's a tip
job and I need a haircut right I I want
her to say
yeah I would have liked if she faked in
a little bit okay it's kind of like a
DOT you don't want a doctor to be like
Jesus what the [ __ ] is that right
bedside manner for a bedside management
type thing well Barbers it's a weird
thing because they ever go to a place
where they have like the uh the game on
they'll like a soccer game yeah I'm like
I don't want you really passionate about
a team while holding scissors next time
or or they're in a conversation with a
guy next to him like oh you see that
game man and I'm like look at me
[ __ ] and I also hate the haircut
because you have to watch it happen
you're sitting there looking at your
dumb face and you guys got the the comb
going through it and then he Snips too
much and he's just watching it and you
got to just take it it sucks I always
say uh what I want it to look like and
then I say but cut off a little less Ah
that's good always because they always
go too sure if it's a new person always
go to especially for us with curly hair
yeah I gave my hair my I cut my hair
once during the pandemic oh boy and it I
thought I did a good job until I
showered and then it it wasn't curled it
just this much but the curl then it went
goes a long way yeah because it doesn't
have that strength to
you said with guys like me is they'll do
the cauliflower look they'll just do
this and leave it here I'm like that's
not what the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah you're
high and tight though is that not how
you like it this is solid though it's a
good look say so all right I'm trying to
trying to but you also are away she did
you want us to yeah you want us he said
to us you want people yeah I got a lot I
got a tube I went to Barber not my
friend I did have a lot of people do the
you got a haircut but they didn't say
they just acknowledged that I got turned
on pouring it on it looks good you look
good sharp all right yeah when they
acknowledge but don't say like there
were people say hey I saw your show
but they didn't say I'm sure that they
liked it if they're telling me they saw
it but still you know okay I don't know
but I don't say you can't say thank you
to that I and it sounds sounds
aggressive but I go okay
yeah that's fair I mean it's a Mitch
Hedberg joke the guys like I saw you at
the the airport but I did he did not say
whether I was good oh I don't remember
that I'm [ __ ] it up but he's like I
saw your show last night but didn't say
if it was good so he goes I saw you oh
you're here or whatever I'm [ __ ] it
up no dude you're these are okay [ __ ]
you let that clip in I was at the
airport a guy came up he said dude I saw
you on TV last night but he did not say
whether or not I thought it was good he
just confirmed that I was on television
so I turned my head away from him for
about a minute and I turn it back I said
dude I saw you at the airport
about a minute ago
you were good
after I'm becoming I'd be like my period
is Jewish period is syncing with you
guys oh that's sweet though yeah it's
it's a man of Chef it's is that right
are you into Jew food
I love DeLisle Google Jewish pastries uh
outside of the homantosh and I don't
favor too much
time pull it up so it's like a Native
American moment
there was um uh Purim you're familiar I
know Purim that's a Jewish Halloween uh
yes and the villain of this is uh Heyman
do you remember that did you have that
growing up yeah
but he would wear a hat
um uh and I always thought that Heyman
Homan Tashan I don't know if that's the
case but he wore a hat that was kind of
like a triangle a pointy hat okay so I
think of uh homintage and as Haman it's
also from that same
Purim have you made this Association Sam
speaker I've never made that but he was
actually a holocaust Survivor hey man oh
hey man no this is way before that yeah
I was trying to do a [ __ ] Magneto
thing I don't know
all right I want to see this Haven
because this is a whole world I have no
idea she's a holocaust Survivor too
Thanos was really he was the thickest
Holocaust Survivor there was that guy
was thick
I don't know this guy yeah that's how
you spell type in Heyman you never saw
it nah that's not my cup what's that my
cup either but I ended up going what
Avengers yeah it's everyone's cup my mom
loves it you watched the last two you'll
love them yeah the last two were fun
okay I just got into the boys you guys
watch that I haven't seen so so
propaganda click on that other have you
seen Peacemaker yet I'm that's next but
people are raving it's good peacemaker's
good this is how people see Jews holy
[ __ ] but doesn't that hat look like a
I've never seen this picture doesn't
that look like a home entashing yeah
yeah it looks more like an Irish guy
pull up a picture
this is something yeah yeah look at that
oh that's that that's what I'm saying
it's a Napoleon hat oh they're delicious
yeah what is that grape in there there's
grape strawberry my favorite is apricot
that's good it's a Jewish Danish right
got it got it it's a little dryer is
regular considered Jewish yeah ruggle is
[ __ ] good dude people love it
I just I know I don't like to read about
it we used to put it in the freezer even
better Frozen I don't know wow Jesus
is that one of the is that a WNBA team
what's the daily storm are you serious
good I'm glad you don't know I've never
heard that if Mark was like oh I get
that one bookmarked they feature my
stuff well what's the daily storm well I
buy border of deduction I have to assume
it's like a news for anti-jewish
government I've never heard that okay I
thought he made it up but the reference
sounds like it sounds like a weather
station oh is that one that's called
there's yeah Jews Love The Weather
Channel
wait a minute daily Stormer okay is it
American far right Neo Knights the white
supremacist islamophobic and I don't
think they wrote this uh bio
I have more respect for them
we're gonna lean into it yeah that would
be fun kind of like what your uh girl
who cut your hair did yeah oh Alex Jones
is top build this house I stand without
who stands with Alex Jones after that
[ __ ] you see the Roses
up there oh yeah look at that
ah free Ricky that's you
free Ricky you know my my brother do you
guys have senior quotes in your your
books yeah sure my brothers was from
Major League forget the curveball Ricky
give him the heater and there was a
teacher I forgot his name but he came up
to me and and said how beautiful my
relationship is with my brother and how
great advice that is and he thought to
me like Rick don't worry about just
trying Dodge stuff just go right to what
you want um I like that well I met your
you got a great family thank you I met
his dad his dad owns like this carpet
land oh Marshall Carpet One it's amazing
it's like high-end top shelf beautiful
Carpeting and uh your dad's the coolest
thank you great guy he's like Sam
Elliott Cleveland Cleveland Classic
right yeah well Marshall corporate one
and rug Gallery is the problem with it
is a lot of people get confused because
you go and a lot of times you're a
customer one sec you're a customer for
these rugs but we don't have any
customers uh it was a little we have
family
no we had people going through you did
you were the first one we recorded at
the rug store there was customers going
through it was an honor yeah we're doing
a podcast some guy behind us like
feeling the material and [ __ ] and he was
happy and Jews know about that's true
materials oh yeah you know why because
because when they had they had to learn
the trades because then they were
leaving Eastern Europe they couldn't
necessarily take their brick and mortar
stores that's why you see a lot of
lawyers and doctors and salesmen because
it's a trade that you could teach and
bring with you wherever you go you don't
need Goods correct but then but then you
guys had fabric as well well and spices
but that's just because that's what the
resources are over there a lot of a lot
of fashion as Jews brought that over a
lot of Ralph Lauren change his name lip
shits not gonna for me to decide I think
that's his real name oh also if you're
talking about who created all the
superheroes it's a lot of Jews yes and
it's a lot of them had like the original
ones Superman yeah and Spider-Man Stan
Lee Jesus Christ was Jewish the original
original superhero that's right but a
lot of them came with like a dark secret
that they were hiding a double life kind
of yeah it made sense that it was like
in low stomach acid yeah Jews were great
boxers
like this yeah
what's that the early Superman he's
always chugging Pepto that was his
weakness and it's Krypton and then the
right stomach but yeah yeah I think
that's what they thought uh goys looked
like with Superman hmm you know because
you guys couldn't throw a ball and stuff
also in order to hot to fit in and you
have to wear glasses and be like well
Lois I think my dick may be a little too
small that was Clark Kent in the daily
planet right exactly originally he was
at the daily Stormer
it's crazy that would be a different a
fascinating comic book
just anti-semitic Superman
like in like North Korea the way they
they repurpose these stories yes yes
he's just stopping bar mitzvahs and
stuff you know he's bringing to the wall
of a temple good times you know that's
why uh when you uh I just officiated my
first wedding
and uh boy or my arms tired did you
really I did uh Eric Griffins and I got
it I did a thing and it was great and it
was Jewish and um he's Jewish he's
married a Jewish uh into Judaism and uh
were you stepping on the glass and I've
heard all these different things I never
knew what the stepping on the glass was
at the end and I learned that it's it's
to symbolize the uh destruction of the
first two Jewish temples to for people
to remember that even on this blessed
joyous day to still remember where you
come from and paint and it just feels
like not such a Jewish thing I know
we're having a good time but I thought
it was in reference to die hard when he
had to walk on the glass
and I think DieHard maybe used that in
it because Die Hard came way after the
destruction of the temples yeah good
point you know he's got the best joke
about the uh the broken glass you know
Mike Kaplan yeah he's a joke he goes you
know we had I had a divorce it was a
very uh it was a Jewish divorce we took
a broken glass we put it back together
that's great is he Jewish
um yeah that's funny
you won a first date not knowing where
to go you guys get Bar Mitzvah yeah oh
fun Should we cut us some footage
this is a translation of my tour portion
nizavin from the book of Deuteronomy
you make a couple bucks a little yeah
one one thick eyebrow the picture like I
can't look at this [ __ ] oh really do we
have to take care of that now oh yeah
how often do you do it not often not too
often thank God but it's yeah how do you
do it I pluck it I get a little tweezer
yeah whoa are you familiar with laser
should I do that I had my back lasered
really what pull back can we see it yeah
so your lower back was if my upper
back's a problem I had my whole back
really upper and lower
is that expensive I don't look at prices
did it hurt uh it hurts a little bit
yeah I mean no more than you know what
you would think how long does it hurt
it's just
it's probably for like a whole back
you're probably looking at a half hour
but it's fine and they also give you
this numbing cream that if you choose to
which I mean a week later no right away
right away you're fine wow I mean there
are some like you stay out of the Sun
for a few days there are some bumps
sometimes sure but I it's I was I was so
insecure about my body hair why what
about the chest well that that for so I
didn't have really body hair and
coincidentally until I started eating
[ __ ] I really do think it's a
coincidence but I started at like seven
or eight years old no no no 17. oh okay
um and I started to negate you I just
didn't want to lie about my I'm not
eating [ __ ] before I kiss sure um I do
now but finally so uh I didn't have
chest hair in high school and the girl I
was dating in high school I also dated
freshman year of college yeah I remember
I went to her dorm and they shared a
floor the guys and the girls and I
showered in the guys shower it was a
different time and when I walked down to
her room I was just a towel over my
waist and she goes
chest hair and like that I just became
soaked for years until ironically I saw
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine and I thought
you look great great and I'm like I
don't have all of that but like that
that's kind of the thing pull up Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine shirtless yeah it
would be the first one man's man peak of
a man I just thought yeah you know what
Chester is okay but I still I love
Chester back hair shoulder hair that's
tough it's tough It's debatable but
Magnum PI was all chest air we gotta do
the older one because he less Chester
I'm a little annoyed that he shaved it
there he looked cool Harry Tom says
that's more my mom is into that I I
think my mom too well I'm trying to get
your mom on board dude
I chest here I usually women are into it
I had one girl when I was in college
don't have it as much she was still
young she was young I bet she grows into
that yeah chest hair is fine you know a
lot of people talk about these beauty
standards that are impossible to connect
to by you know having large breasts to
large ass fat lips of juicy wet [ __ ]
and a narrow a waste and just you know
beautiful and skinny sure but not
everybody could look that way but guys
have that too with hair yes and a lot of
people because because a lot of these
chiseled model types don't have hair I
feel like girls like
until you hit maybe 25 or older because
I remember back when I was younger and I
was fooling around with some girls that
were a bit younger oh yeah yeah they
they usually they didn't tell me I hate
your [ __ ] chest there but you could
tell really and then when I once once
that maybe like hit 27 definitely in the
30s and you started hooking up with
younger women again and and I was
hooking up with younger women
I don't think I've ever yes I have
I [ __ ] a 17 year old once really well
I was 17. but yes key word that's
allowed yeah
um but uh yeah older like I I don't know
if it's if it's rude to say older is 27
or 30 but that's around when I started
recognizing that yeah like once I was uh
in the upper in the 20s women tend to
like chest hair they love it my guilt
and I'm so glad she wants me to have
more which sucks because I'm like well
it's not gonna happen well now I know
why Dane Cook waxes his chest
uh they like some young so I don't like
to speak of other people all right or of
other pastries I think most guys like a
young lady I mean I I was gonna say I
don't think I've ever dated a younger
girl but that's not true because my last
girlfriend is younger
um like I was younger other than that oh
it's oh yeah it's usually been my age
but yeah my last one was younger yeah
but you know these are
my when I met her she was 26 27. happy
birthday thank you huh now word from our
sponsor better help you have to take
care of your mind folks we spent so much
time taking care of our skin our hair
our teeth and so little care of the most
important body part the brain how well
you take care of your brain affects how
you experience life investing time and
energy and mental health is crucial to
being happy eating right working out and
getting plenty of sleep are a good start
but no substitution for talk therapy
better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable we
love therapy it's good for you don't let
those bags pile up everybody's got [ __ ]
in their life everybody's got drama you
gotta make it work you gotta be healthy
and that's how you do it is talking
about it that's how you get it out
better help is online there it offers
video phone and chat therapy sessions
you can choose to not see anyone on
camera and it's much more affordable
than in person you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours we might be
drunk listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com drunk that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash drunk get
on it if you haven't heard already it's
smooth sex summer the leading the leader
in below the belt grooming is making
sure we all have a ball this summer by
giving your pants
Partners everything they need to stay
fresh I love this thing you gotta love
the manscape performance package 4.0
it's got it all I use this thing on my
sack I go around the base of the shaft
you just want a little extra length and
uh no better equipment than these guys
manscape did it right they got a goddamn
headlight on the thing yeah and uh yeah
you can't Nick you can't cut I mean
there's a lot of veins down there and a
lot of uh precious material you don't
want to ruin I just use it man it's it's
I feel lighter it's great yeah it works
I had a [ __ ] fro covering my balls
yeah big fan our pubes look like our
hair so uh it's not that different and
you need a real I got sideburns too I
need a real mower down there the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and weed
whacker knows and ear hair trimmer
features proprietary Advanced Skin safe
technology to perfect protect your
delicate parts and holes both are
waterproof so you can shave in the
shower come on get it all out in one go
manscape even threw in two free gifts to
their performance package 4.0 the
manscape boxers and shed travel bag take
a look at the shears 2.0 a luxury nail
crewman get grooming kit I keep one of
my my bag all the time this kit includes
stainless steel nail cutters tweezers
and grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady in bed with those feet get 20
percent off and free shipping with the
code drunk at manscaped.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com it's smooth sex
summer boys get on board or get left
behind with your hairy ball bag either
way I wish I had a little chest there is
what I'm saying I got some weird nipple
stragglers some some Rogue great
antennae coming out there is that the
nipple or the hairs the hairs but the
middle as I got I got nothing
interesting so you're the opposite of
Hugh he has a lot in the middle the
middle is where you want it is it yeah
look at look at you wanna you wanna have
anything he could have anything and I'll
give it to him too Hugh Jackman's
[ __ ] talented he's uh I'm trying to
get him on the Pod while I'm here really
he can sing dance muscles he's doing the
music man right Elephant Man Elephant
Man oh that was Bradley Cooper yeah what
he shouldn't be the elephant
do you ever see a Hugh Jackman in uh the
one with the magic for Steve yes that's
a good movie great movie what about the
one where it goes from now on
yeah
do you remember no that one the circus
one no I never no what am I talking
about the greatest showman yes
Jewish is it good oh really
last name ends in a man it's usually
Jewish right good point show man yeah
true story about Hugh Jackman he used to
do a Broadway show and apparently my
biological father's in the crowd one
night he is doing like crowd work brings
him on stage and he wrote like a jingle
for like an ad you know an advertising
thing back in the day whatever he used
to do Jingles like Rick Vaughn in
Two and a Half Men yeah that's a little
bit kinda and he had a jingle yes
Charlie Sheen dude oh can you know act
like you've been there we're trying to
get sheen on the Pod I thought it was
saying Rick Vaughn and Major League was
played by Charlie Sheen I I get that but
you combined well I put it together okay
okay
we've got a Sheen update uh oh yeah from
our buddy Simon Rex who uh who was
trying to get Charlie Sheen on this spot
we desperately want Charlie are you a
big Charlie Sheen fan we just think he's
like a perfect we might be drunk yes yes
we are we are fans yeah he seems fun
yeah
but uh yeah apparently he's in he's
hiding in the Hills he doesn't do a lot
of public appearances he just does porn
but I still but Simon Rex for those of
you who love the Simon Rex episode not
only is he a great guess he's a great
guy he's pushing for Sheen hell yeah
we're fighting for Sheen we're gonna get
shade one day but anyway Hugh Jackman
brings him my biological dad on stage
and it was like play what do you do when
you go and he goes oh I used to do
advertising now I write songs and stuff
and he goes well play one he goes I can
I can't sing and he's like please play
when he gets the whole crowd to be like
play it play it plays the song bombs
shits his pants now
balls over the stool
drop's dead yeah no he plays the song
and and everyone like he can't sing but
everyone just cheers because he did it
yeah right crazy new Jackman's like
that's incredible that song I love that
song I'm Gonna Make That song I'm not
kidding I'm gonna make that song never
got in touch
we got [ __ ] ghosted by Jackman dude
yeah
I think in his heart he really did want
to but yeah we're just too busy he's
busy he's got Tenors movies in the works
but that's wild I don't remember if we
talked about this but you obviously have
a non-biological dad as well the best
yeah um biological dad though is in your
life not really lives like seven blocks
for me it's very strange they they walk
by each other on the sidewalk like this
if you guys Bond over issues with your
family
yeah we're both pretty good my family's
good I mean yeah it was his I mean we're
we're well adjusted my parents had
dinner the other night oh how did I know
that I saw that on something I think we
posted it
we posted it something yeah I saw either
a clip or or something Norman's in the
morels and you didn't know that they
called you no we both got blindsided
with it yeah they were having dinner
with the Normans I was like oh that's so
cool but not your biological dad no no
no but you're a biological dad yes well
no but my mom is my biological mom my
dad is technically my stepdad but he's
legally adopted me he's my dad how old
are you when he adopted you well when
they got married uh they were like I was
probably like seven so right okay good
age good age when I started masturbating
yeah dude you weren't [ __ ] in there
well I called you a shower play yeah
dude play yeah yeah did you guys [ __ ]
stuff around the house who didn't all
right I used to I remember nothing safe
and a young man no no in a young boy
well if there was a mattress you're
gonna [ __ ] it yeah man can I tell you
the best mattress I've ever [ __ ]
sister honestly you could get one at
helixsleep.com
to save up to 200 off all mattress
orders here's the best part and two free
pillows hey nothing wrong with that yeah
you know they have a 20-day guarantee
what psych 100 days free and if you
don't like it they'll come to your house
and pick it up for free take the
two-minute sleep quiz at helixsleep.com
what about the drool though what have
you drool on it will they still take it
back yep all right because I'm a drooler
you drooling yourself you draw on your
pillow though not on your mattress
pillow yeah but you said pillow
you caught me
I used to I used to have um I remember
when I was a little boy I discovered
that if you put pressure on your penis
it feels good yeah so I would have uh I
remember there was a sleepover uh with
another heterosexual friend uh and we
would put pillows on our on our Schwans
and step on it whoa doesn't this feel
good like you don't know what it is
doesn't that feel good and remember we
tried we would lay on our stomachs and
put a pillow on our butts and stand on
it and you can't feel it the same yeah
yeah you know it's uh I used to do the
circle jerk how old 36. you were younger
no not sir we didn't get in a circle but
you know he would take the couch I would
take the bed he would take the clothes
all the four of us we were square wait
and do what we would put on a porn and
jerk yeah under a blanket people do that
but really you wouldn't just masturbate
next to your friends I mean they were
you know it's like where he was yeah
yeah and I have a bit about this in my
new special oh really yeah about how we
used to do that oh okay I think that's
pretty I'll start doing a bit about that
if it works I think we all gonna do it
but I think we should do a circle jerk
bit of us doing a circle jerk sure yeah
and there was no embarrassment no no I
mean we were young boys figured out we
didn't know what was going on really you
know very young and I remember one time
my friend finished and we're all talking
about it
what it is Adi just and he had it on his
hand and I go I dare you to taste it and
he goes I don't want dude I go come on
taste it and he goes we haven't talked
since that was like 20 years ago yeah it
is I guess you can say it let's get him
on the phone you could say a 13 year old
jizz I don't think you say a 13 year old
nutted not it doesn't sound right right
it is
everything needs to be contextualized
and we've kind of lost that right now
with these sound bites and these bubbles
that we live in left this right that the
truth is when you're 13 and you nut it's
not about a 13 year old nutting it's
about you and your peers nutting but
everyone needs to Define this stuff you
have people on the left saying that
Trump is you know that stuff yeah okay
and then you got the people on the right
saying you know all the stuff they're
saying Cox the daily Stormer and we're
picking teams like like it's the Cavs
versus the Bulls yeah I know instead of
picking policies and we'll just go with
whatever team we decided oh I like
LeBron only if he's on the Cavs [ __ ]
that God is a woman yeah here here
silent tree I don't like to choose size
I don't choose uh people yes yes
uh
uh there were no Jews in the building
oh that's 9 11. I thought that's what
you were doing oh okay I don't know I
don't have any uh platitude you don't
have any good ones the same exact thing
all you have to do is just turn it on
its head it's the same exact thing you
do switch one variable huh wait what uh
you know uh [ __ ] guys are have huge
dicks and they they're awesome right
that's like something you could do but
instead switch it to either say women
have uh or guys have small oh I see I
see what's one of your jokes that that's
cutting that is like that is like what's
a good one or two liner that you have
that people at first might be like oh
black people are lesser right now switch
it okay black people are on top same job
just different point of view okay well
this is not gonna help anybody's career
this one Flag by YouTube already we have
lost all our sponsors and it's been a
good run we will be moving to the Daily
Stormer for future content he looks
stuck with with us believe it or not
what's your Helix code you should get
the code you guys have Helix I'm a
Casper man are you oh yeah
he's friendly I've had the same measures
forever I might have to update at some
point my friend Ryan Hamilton has a new
thing that I guess he heard on the Tim
Ferriss podcast it's like a cooling
thing that you can control from your
phone makes your bed cool
temperature of your bed hot as hell cool
his eyes are hot as hell you guys don't
have hell yeah we don't we don't have
any either though do we oh no I don't
really no I think we don't I don't think
unless of course you're talking about
Jack's Deli
yeah something like that I would urinate
on that and short it out I saw in Shark
Tank there's uh there's a thing that you
could buy that that thing what is that
where you could you could heat or cool
and you could do different temperatures
on different sides looks like she's
about to suck the old [ __ ] look at all
these new inventions I'm way behind I'm
sleeping on straw you ever get get into
a bed and the and and the pillow's cold
and it's just like oh I love a cold
pillow I think this is supposed to give
you that all night with my ex the whole
bed was cold
all right no I don't like to speak
negative people no she's great
just for a joke
for a job she was a cold on the inside
okay all right all right all right
what is that one seven best bed cooling
systems okay so this is a thing I didn't
know about this yeah remember the old
days you put a nickel in the slot it
would Shake
is that where you that was in movies I'd
see that where they go to a hotel it's
like a shit-up box Hotel
they call them they call them Jewish
beds
all right it's only a nickel but they
were called Michael J fox I don't like
to
[ __ ] blew it God damn it there it is
relaxation service yeah I think it was a
quarter what do you think that does for
you I don't I think it's just vibrating
we just had so little entertainment like
remember that the thing you'd go to at
the gym and you put it around your waist
it would jiggle you I mean from the 30s
yeah I went to a cheap gym this guy's
training with Jack LaLanne
remember the football game where they
would just go yeah
and then you see dude pull up what NBA
2K 23 is going to look like oh the
graphics just pull up a clip of just a
game it's insane what the graphic is
though
I mean this is the most realistic
looking that's not who gives a [ __ ]
about it but look at their face you
could see like this oh look at that yeah
2K when 2K first came out it was for
Dreamcast it was like incredible
unbelievable yeah dude 99.99 yes yeah
wow they got to get domestic violence in
these games though if they want it to be
real I heard in the new Madden game uh
DeShaun Watson you can come on a
masseuse that's crazy but would that be
for isn't that more of a football thing
than a basketball thing yeah yeah no I
said for Madden well gotcha do is that
that's your team that's got to be kind
of weird right
uh well he's talking the bronze I don't
really watch football because of the
abuse
the Indians still Indians now they're
called the guardians Guardians you know
I have a uh I just actually reposted it
I have this clip of my family that goes
viral whenever I post it it's it's wild
let's hear it and uh well maybe we'll
put it up okay but he my dad it was this
was five years ago he's wearing a Chief
Wahoo shirt and so many comments I think
it's people trolling but still so many
comments about how unacceptable it is
but nobody thought it was unacceptable
until somebody told him it was exactly I
don't have skin in the game I really
could care less you know of [ __ ] in
the game
but and if you went downstairs in the
basement and got a soda what was the
[ __ ] rule
okay I don't like the the people who are
like who are like
I want to feel good about myself let me
tear dude times were different people
make mistakes I don't like the ganging
up on people who used to masturbate with
little boys yeah different times still
used to yeah I mean Jesus Christ This
Guy's the king yes come on I didn't know
that oh yeah I bought Epstein's Island
you bought it yeah yeah it was cheap
your YouTube Bargain Bin prices damn I
can still call it Epstein's Island you
can't change it he's laying did you keep
it one of us have we got to get his jet
I bet it's a disc you know I heard he
got that jet from what's his name the
guy who who started uh found Victoria's
Secret he's from uh he's from Ohio this
guy oh yeah what's his name oh wow
you're talking about Super Rich yeah and
uh and he he gave Epstein power of
attorney for all of his finances because
he was the finance guy so there was some
stuff that he uh all the things that he
acquired but he bought the Jet and it's
not publicly the price but it said at
his at a discount rate or whatever yeah
apparently it was like gifted to him so
I'm saying like he got it for very cheap
so maybe you can interesting look up a a
Jew go look up Ohio Victoria's Secret I
liked I like the idea of buying it why
is this so cheap well
a guy last guy in this less Western
pedophile that's it Les Wexner yeah
shout out to Lex will put his Instagram
handle up here he's very rich Bath and
Body Works Abercrombie how bad is
Victoria's Secret if he's willing to do
this you know an interesting interesting
backstory on Les Wexner is
his father was in the clothing business
and he worked for his dad and things it
just it wasn't working well he said that
he wasn't a good like good at his job
the father said about Lex yeah that's
where he went because Lex suggested our
sports bras are the thing that's selling
the most we should really focus on that
he goes you'll never be a Salesman so
let's start his own place called The
Limited because it was a limited
selection of just the things that he
thought would do really well yeah that
turned into the limited and then he did
all the other stuff oh I love a good
origin yeah love a good origin yeah you
know uh
well this is not really An Origin but I
heard a fun fact lately if we're doing
those yeah what do you guys think okay
so Uber let me see if you can guess this
Uber
came in you know it was new Newber and I
you know changed the game but the city
lost a ton of money on Uber can you
think about why
but why they lost money on Uber why the
city lost less tickets close let's
parking let's
lesser drunk driving incidents that's it
really so DUIs went way down with Uber
coming in and the DUIs make a lot of
money for the city no one thinks about
that and they lost hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of dollars damn I mean they
want you to get a drink they want you to
get it it helps the you know lawyer fees
court fees jail you know tickets car
reimburse whatever the hell plus yes
less deaths yeah but you know it's all
about money man it is it's all about
money mo money mo power Mo Money Mo
Problems Mo Money Mo Welsh Mo Mandel
well blood you got two Mo's in there
well and none of the Stooges aha I was
thinking but I can't remember his name
his last name does he have he has to
have morocca that sounds right I believe
you don't be a Sunday morning old school
Daily Show no I'm talking about from The
Simpsons his last name oh Sizzler what
thank you yes maybe the best Simpsons
character he's one of the best he might
be the best
um he's got one of my favorite tips is
jokes Carl no they uh they get him up on
the lie detector when Mr Burns dies they
go where were you on Saturday night he
goes I was uh on a hot date and all
right dinner with friends and all right
dinner alone and all right I was ugly
the women in this Victoria's Secret
catalog at Sears catalog ding
what a way to go for that joke oh dude
can you pull up his his NRA speech the
mo NRA speech it's one of the best
[ __ ] it's incredible I don't know
this one oh dude please get it flaming
bow no the
uh-oh what happened oh he's putting the
speakers on so we can hear it
like a hug happiness it's just a flaming
mode wow
wait I wanna I don't know you could sing
are you allowed to show stuff like that
do you care about that I think it was
shorter
yeah hurricane my favorites my favorite
Simpsons joke and it taught me uh this
joke structure that is one of my
favorites is Stone Cutters oh great up
when he goes uh
Homer's trying to get away because he
wants to see what Lenny and Carl are
doing because he doesn't realize they're
in the in the stonecutters already yeah
and he Marge doesn't want him to do that
kind of stuff so he's getting up in the
dinner table and she goes how many where
are you going and he tries to figure out
he goes I'm going to
stock
Lenny and Carl I just said what the
thing was and I I blew my mind you could
just say the thing say a worse thing
well you're saying that he's just saying
the truth
he's like trying to figure you're not
gonna drink no I'm gonna have a drink
just the case and that you could you
could lead people by by speech patterns
yes I used to I remember I used to like
VHS like try to tape everyone I could
just so I could just bang just watch of
course yes 10 in a row sure you know
pretty TV you should do that with
Britney Spears yeah oh yeah that's
[ __ ] hot one more time yeah do you
have any peeves Rick
I got some peeps do you I have some
peeps I gotta peeve should I buy you
some time are you ready I'm ready but
you could go oh you go yeah
flying but let me zoom in a little bit
because people would be like everyone
hates lying lying and not also I hate
lying so I'm not I'm not just
categorizing this peep I'm just
separating the P from the thing lying
what are we doing but the peeve is where
it serves no purpose and now you're just
discrediting everything I'm on my way
over let's say I'm gonna be here in 18
minutes okay I'm five minutes away ah
just tell me the thing I did that
yesterday I feel bad because you're
trying to soften it yeah you're trying
to soften it for the other person
oh man did I get my ass reamed out did I
make the gig on time we made the gig it
was all fine oh this is the Philadelphia
thing I was late no no no well
Pennsylvania but either way it was ugly
but I I thought I could make it because
I had the A train I was literally on the
A train I said I'll be there in five you
know five is a loose term but I thought
I could make it in five it's three so
people that it's not a loose turn it's
not a loose people just take it because
it's divisible with ten I guess it just
uh you know it's one of the
idiosyncrasies I would almost call it
even though it's not but you said you
don't do them it's your version of a
platitude you're just offering something
something that's going to ease them but
it's not sustainable yeah and it bites
you in the ass later it's better to bite
it up top that's why I like that she
said I'm sorry
yeah I like the sorry about the haircut
just although I do think you look um I
mean you honestly look yeah so good it's
why my legs have been crossed this whole
episode we see that [ __ ] hog no no no
come on let me see it what if I didn't I
just just a [ __ ] rock
patreon.com it's funny about lasers we
built these lasers we thought it was
gonna be shooting aliens and burning
people's eyes out and it just ah we got
some juice hair off yeah that's a bad
hitch and I have a vagina so much is so
much technology is for is is to be
weaponized and is created for that it's
nice that something that was originally
meant to shoot aliens and burn People's
Light eyes out or at least let's give
this Jewish person a little less
Neurosis yeah yeah and Lasik is pretty
amazing it's kind of burning their eyes
out though ah true but it helps them
have you had it no my friend had an idea
to give him a ride
because you know once you get out of
there a little you're a little wonky you
can't drive after lasik no it's like an
abortion right
although you could drive after an
abortion it's not like an abortion there
aren't people protesting outside don't
you dare get rid of those eyes I'll tell
you something if prescription glasses
were part of the same pharmaceutical
company that all of our drugs are I bet
you it would be an issue the government
has they don't care if you're sick they
just want to keep you alive so you could
pay for more my eyes my choice good
merch yes but you but but you make
Choice look really blurry
that's great we have a good time here
though that's fun any other peeves
that's a great peeve good people all
right how about this one this is a
relationship peeve so no offense are you
a huge seeing anyone uh no not with
those eyes but all right so uh great
eyes I have a stigmatism
I take it back what the [ __ ] put those
back on googly oh good lord go holy hell
Jesus all right so uh
how about this one
I'm drinking here good God
ah you're hideous okay so gotta regroup
but uh how about this one the my lady
does this hey have you seen the uh the
remote
and I go huh the remote it's like three
places the remote could be the couch the
table or the chair or whatever she's
like I can't find the remote but she
never looked she's doing the where is
the remote without looking you gotta
look first then ask me because then I
walk in the living room and I go it's on
the arm of the couch what are you crazy
but she didn't look she just goes
where's the remote she had two seconds
of I need this in my hand it's not in my
hand I don't feel like looking I'll ask
you
no look it's kind of like when you text
when you're talking to somebody on text
and they ask you a question that they
could have Googled ah that's a good
that's not a pet peeve of mine I'm just
saying it's like you just want me to do
it for you want me to do it that's what
it is right you could have looked I
looked so now I'm coming in and doing
your job and giving it to you when you
want to I don't want the remote I'll go
a peeve to jump off your piece jump is
when people say where's the and then
they go oh here it is uh you haven't
even finished the sentence
yes all the time yeah where's the you
just found it same vein yeah yeah you
know like you didn't look it's like you
said you just wanted me to do it
and that one was so egregious that
they'd even finish the sentence before
they found it yeah so [ __ ] him sorry
no I'm just saying it's horrible we need
to pee Furious yeah yeah yeah hey bud
I'm sorry thank you I need a full thank
you don't [ __ ] with me Sean yeah how
about any rest you gotta peeve no that
was kind of nice oh okay I have another
peep that's in the lion category yeah
but if it's more subconscious when
somebody tells you something that is
when it's not but they think like um how
do you spell pepto-bismo
p-e-p-t-a-m-o-s-a-l there's you know
maybe they put the question mark in
there at least with the question mark
Cadence I know that you don't know
that's good but what if you don't know
if they say it and and it's like say I
think it's yeah or it might be people
are people are so afraid to say I don't
know they really are yeah talking to you
Twitter
pull up Twitter
no don't pull up Twitter just say I
don't know and just say I don't know
you're right I don't know it's hard yeah
no you know what's hard
having an identity that you might not
know everything and projecting that onto
other people I'll tell you what's hard
15 years in a hunter in prison that's
[ __ ] hard
yeah I'll tell you what's hard Rick's
dick after that haircut yeah dude that
[ __ ] look that's a rocket that's a cross
leg very sweet dong dude thank you very
much I can tell you got a decent dunk
you know how I can tell
arm
see that forearm does forearm show what
length of forearm and then you got a
solid by and you don't work out I I
started working out again a little bit
recently but it's more physical therapy
after my surgery that's very different I
had a penis reduction your penis
reduction I did I really did damn I
might have a short coming out I really
did I'm so sorry it's all right it's 10
inches now oh all right she kept it
small hard
guy doesn't know how to emphasize yeah
my dick's only eight inches when it's
hard well they had a kid who was born
with a gigantic dong and the doctor was
like we got to do surgery because it's
gonna he's gonna die and so they were
like we'll knock it down so they left it
at nine
yeah that's that's not bad your son is
uh six pounds his dick is five and a
half yeah yeah do you know there's some
people that penises they don't get
bigger just fills with blood so it just
goes like this
oh wow I like the idea of one of those
labs like a little tiny baby in a pickle
jar and his dick is just
a laser at it yeah
any wrecks
well one that I have I kind of already
did which is
um if you have heartburn stomach
problems indigestion diarrhea peppermint
peppermint oil now there's this brand
that I love huge for us and I pushed it
a lot it's called IB guard and it's
incredible however I mean it's really a
magic pill and I've been pushing it to a
lot of people but I looked recently and
I didn't I apologize it has a green dye
in it that is not one of the better food
coloring coloring dies so I recently
switched although I still take it when I
need it but I recently switched to just
natural peppermint oil what the hell
it's really magic dude if you have a
irritable bowel if you if you're not
feeling well take it within 10 minutes
whoa cramping diarrhea bloating
constipation gas gives you all this just
does the same [ __ ] as Pepto but it's not
as bad for you it's it's it's not
getting rid of your acid it's calming it
down you know I have a quick little
Atlantic donut I had a lot of pastors
what a classy way to say I'm going to
[ __ ] myself immediately it's kind of
like saying instead of saying uh poor
and hungry saying like food insecure
yeah yeah
you tell like they talk to some you know
some people it's a person of size
that's a real one oh yeah so what's the
anecdote
I ate a lot of pasta and I put a lot of
Basil on it it felt great the next day I
finished the pasta was out of Basil I
had a stomach ache I thought is it the
pasta
is it the basil later I found out much
like mint it helps you with digestion so
eating basil mint is actually really
really good but if you don't have it on
you IB guard you got to try some man I'm
gonna try okay dude I'm gonna order all
this [ __ ] tonight hell yeah you think
this is a game Rick I'm [ __ ] all in
dude I'm getting magnesium too magnesium
helps you sleep that's what I heard but
mag07 helps you [ __ ] oh okay and Magneto
helps you get out of the Holocaust and
magnanimous is what we should sometimes
do to people in the room because we
remember what it was like masturbating
in a bath yeah dude yeah they're sitting
in your own semen no well yeah you you
have to shower I always shower after a
bath what what are you doing three hours
in the in the shower I take a bath to
relax not to clean myself and I almost
only bathe in a hotel I get nice hotels
I love a bath you're like a rom-com
thanks man okay my friend Nick Griffin
you know our buddy is a bit where he
said uh he's on the phone with his
friend he goes hey I'm taking a bath
let's go get lunch he goes that's cool
I'm not hungry anymore
you're just sitting in your own stew
yeah your own Phil that's why you shower
after or you could shower before I know
some people shower before getting here
before so I told you to shut up easy
but you got a shower before that's what
they say
okay I'm learning a lot this is this is
a weird one I have a I have a wreck for
you that I haven't tried yet yeah
um
first I'll tell you what I have tried I
don't do a lot of condiments I know on
my mother's child I guess she does but
unrelated I love condiments I very
limited but when you eat turkey you need
something and a lot of these fun oils
are not good oil so I don't eat them I
recently started putting hummus oh
hummus hummus pickles turkey and a lot
of lettuce I like that but somebody
suggested to me because I I want to eat
more fish because
and I don't love mayonnaise but I like
tuna fish he suggested I haven't tried
yet instead of mayonnaise in your tuna
fish hummus whoa heard of that yeah me
neither I go Ranch
it's like mayonnaise but flavorful yeah
all right all right
I'm not a big Ranch guy I like mayo
though all right I like Mayo like
mustard uh yeah mustard on Turkey is is
tops I do because I'm a deli boy I'm a
deli brat and I love to get potato
pancakes so sometimes either pastrami or
turkey or both uh I'll get rid of one of
the one of the Buns one of the the Rye
Breads and I'll make it the potato
pancake on the top oh and then I dip so
it's Pastrami and or turkey lettuce uh a
lot of times I'll take the pickle I'll
cut so I have some slices pieces of
pickle and I dip the whole sandwich into
applesauce wow a great I I think I might
do that tonight where's that at Subway
I think we're all done with the honey
oat and the fake crab aren't you doing
well you eat at Subway still well I'm
just saying they could add that to the
roster no I don't need something you're
trying to connect to the to the common
folk by talking about Subway well I like
kids but no I don't I eat Subway every
day for like five years I used to too
yeah I don't like subway but I thought
Jared was terrific yeah you heard what
happened what he did with him and Chris
Rock right huh how you hit Chris Rock
hit him like Will Smith
at the Oscars Jared Fogle for the subway
guy that was I thought that was Will
Smith I'm confused
you just confused Jared Fogle and Will
Smith
yes and I'm embarrassed and for I don't
I want to say this out I'm uh yes they
were two very influential people when I
was a kid and I truly just messed up the
subway pedophile with the King and I'm
sorry all right no problem
but they look alike I'm not saying
Subway is good I'm saying it'd be nice
if sandwich shops started carrying some
[ __ ] like this with the sandwich shop
Quiznos uh Jersey Mike's uh the other
one they're not that's why you that's
why there's all this [ __ ] trash fake
bread [ __ ] yeah and then there's
proper delicatessens yes and if you want
to go to a sandwich shop go to a deli
yeah those are so many good sandwich
shops in New York that aren't those
chains I mean you could you could and
same with Los Angeles you could support
these good sandwich shops you know yeah
just also just like better quality
everything yeah Papa John's yeah that's
our slogan yeah our ingredients better
quality Papa John's yeah a few more
slurs but better quality it's crazy like
like anybody that is it like Dave from
Wendy's anybody that is a character but
also a person from something yeah
Colonel Sanders he had plantations I
think oh yeah like all these people have
all this history so if we think about
like when you uh you know who's the one
good one and it's also it's made up and
he does so much for children and charity
Ronald that's right Ronald McDonald
Ronald McDonald House yeah that helps
kids yeah Ronald McDonald they had to
have a fake owner
to be the spokesperson because everyone
else has so many demons and you get to
write oh well look who's talking deadly
talking to Bruce Willis glass on the
floor not Jewish
but I was gonna go with dad with the
Chief Wahoo we all got we all got
skeletons should we do I mean if we're
lucky
that's a good point
and if you got a skeleton in your closet
there's been a gay guy in there for too
long
this has been a fun one I think the Wii
just kicked in by the way it took a
little bit in time for your table read
right after the spot I didn't have much
I didn't have much oh good is that an
anxiety thing does that help you
medicate I just love it and I was
excited when we were doing this and we
had to change the time because of this
work thing and and I don't really drink
so I wanted to get like uh hi I wanted
you guys to get drunk and meet again
really high to have like a very silly
time so I just had it in my head I'm
like I just did another podcast today
and I didn't want to do anything but for
this one in particular I'm like I want
to get a little something all right we
like that look at the tone of the show
yeah but I had it too late a little uh
altered well uh Rick I'm an altered boy
is there anything you want to plug I
mean obviously shoes off podcast take
your shoes off podcast sure great pod I
have a thing that's coming out but but
uh look how cute wait go back up look at
those photos boy you photograph well
thank you look at that guy thank you
hello would you yeah thick head of hair
yeah yeah oh that's sweet
um so I uh Jack breath man killing it
yeah well it's all downhill after that
but I mean really good stuff like I got
for him he's big we love having my
family right there Darren kill him he's
on SNL
yeah oh Giannis will say so okay Jim
Jeff look at that 140. hey Mario 148.
how do we get Jim Jeff what do you know
that we don't know look at that he's
never New York oh yeah hey pull up you
could cut this out I want you I don't
know if you guys have seen it hit 144.
watch the beginning of this edit this
out because this is this is self
whatever the thing is self-promotion
this is good for your pod all right well
if you guys don't care but I want you to
watch how cool this intro is I can't
wait to see it holy [ __ ] it's like a
street fighter two yes it is
okay big flight to New York cross
country uh shout out to Tom Bates who
who animated this but we worked on it
together
okay we got a giant green dick on the
Empire this is insane dude wow this must
cause you a fort whenever I do a
sleepover whenever I take my stuff on
the road it's called the sleepover
series
oh wow this is bringing me back to my
youth
damn I miss these video games like
Streets of Rage come on how cool is this
look at this you got home alone
you got Jay-Z Will Smith Howard Stern
Trevor Noah me oh my God I have
different outfits
now we're in your hotel comedy still oh
my God you're picking the location come
on isn't this awesome this is incredible
let's just play the pop can we make this
a double length podcast and this podcast
we'll play at the end I mean you gotta
should get an Emmy for that at least a
nomination it's really it's really uh so
cool so plugging the podcast I guess
here I mean I'm really really proud of
this podcast and and my team and I do
such a great job with it and I just uh
I don't I have no memory of this it was
cold out I guess
going out oh I wiped my nose on that one
sorry
are you going back on the road Rick I've
never I went on the road I I went on the
road for a year
like five years ago I've never done the
I'm starting just now I've never done it
I've done like 15 times ever oh the
public would they're clamoring
um we don't need to look at his number
but I have this basketball thing that's
coming out
um what's that uh I say I talked about
on our podcast but I was kicked out of a
basketball game five years ago which was
kind of the inciting incident to a real
life Discovery and self into
self-awareness and it was a really big
powerful moment in my life but the email
that was sent it was I was in Bill
Lawrence's basketball game he's scrubs
and he did my show Undateable and Ted
lasso and he's a very successful big guy
runner producer I mean his basketball
game and he sent me an email saying some
of the guys in the game don't like
playing when you're here whoa oh too
aggressive and blah blah blah and the
shoes weren't on uh and they uh
incidentally one of the issues was I
tied my shoes too much
because I kept having two but that
wasn't why I got kicked out but
they invited me he invited me back um
but he said maybe you should leave for a
little bit because in my head in my head
you're playing to hard and you're doing
whatever you you feel like you need to
do and also being silly and loud and
whatever it is and a lot of them they're
some of them are you know close to 50
and they're comedy writers and they're
just looking to like have a good time
come to the [ __ ] hoop you know and uh
but he sent me this email that was a
beautiful email it was what I wanted
Barber to do for me which is just hey
Rick I don't know if you know how people
see you yeah but there's some issues
here
um and uh that email was beautiful and
also really hard to it was just a it I
felt really bad
um and I made this thing uh uh Joel
McHale plays Bill and he this the script
is is uh the email that he sent me
uh trailer thing he made yeah it's
called I'm phenomenal Ah that's so cool
to use this heartache and make art out
of it oh I was writing something
incidentally pitching it with Bill this
was years ago and I ended up working on
something else and I wasn't allowed to
but I filmed this thing that was just
for me to help me write it because when
you've I found that when I edit stuff I
come up with ideas so let me do that
once
um and then we were pitching the show
and I never finished it and I filmed it
a few years ago yeah and I was watching
it with my editor shout out John Michael
recently and it's really funny so we
made a new ending and we kind of
frankensteined it together
I'm telling you guys too much about this
well is it out can we see it it'll be
out it comes out August 29th oh I can't
wait that's very exciting because I
think Rick Glassman has this great photo
of him playing against LeBron James in
high school which is just an insane
thing now I heard he's really good
Rick's really good if somebody told me
that like he was I think playing a
pickup game with someone like somebody
in entertainment and they're like hey
man like you gotta dial it back a little
bit hit that Baldy
the [ __ ] ball dude you're
not aware of how other people
perceive you what are you talking about
good thing idiot
whoops are you
[Applause]
get it
[ __ ] nuts playing phenomenal I got
big balls
I got a cool guy haircut I got I love
that though yeah so it looks awesome
yeah I sent you some clips yeah it's
really funny thank you oh man I'm
curious amazing comic actor oh he's
great great timing man are we watching
our community apps recently and like God
damn is that guy funny oh yeah great and
Ted remember we were watching yes that's
right it's Bill murray-esque yeah he um
you know he worked with Chevy Chase yeah
on community and he played Chevy Chase
in a few Talent stupid gesture and
he did Chevy Chase yeah he killed him I
mean it's he's so good at that it's also
a very similar Alpha energy type of
thing yeah you know I love that movie
that movie was so fun yeah isn't it yeah
oh that was something I wanted to ask
you oh blanking I hope you're getting
some love on this pod you put so much
work into it it's been doing well okay
good I hope so I'm not part of any of
the groups you know like incidentally uh
you like I love that you guys had me on
this and I love when you did that but uh
that's why I wanted I came out to New
York to do podcasts like I want to start
doing other people's stuff and try to
have other audiences find it it helps
yeah yeah you gotta share it spread them
listen to uh Rick's pod it's he puts so
much work into it thank you it's fun
yeah this is nice you throw me for every
time I do it I think it's gonna be this
and then it's that and the response also
people love you but they were saying but
you've done you've done it I think four
times no three times at least
three we'll say three just once I know
just whenever you're back in L.A I'd
love to have you I think you had a clip
go viral off of that did I I think you
did
I don't know pretty sure you got a big
clip from that um what we all talked
about the amount uh that I first found
out about you no offense this was years
ago uh everybody was commenting to have
you on
um well we have a weirdness
that that gels
pun intended hey there we go yeah those
are weirdness it's nice seeing you be so
accepted for your obviously you've
developed a craft around it like but
like I could so empathize and I'm
projecting I don't know if it's true but
what being a kid what it was like for
you and all the jokes that you had to do
and how uncomfortable you were sure and
then to be able to figure it out but I
connected you very fast over that well I
think you know you got kicked out of a
basketball league basically and I think
that's the key to Comedy is
I'm a weirdo you're a weirdo you're a
weirdo you gotta find the worst thing
about you and kind of it
accentuate it that's why you see fat
guys who are Comics are like I'm the fat
guy because they're like I hate this
about me maybe and that's what I that's
what you guys love about it I remember
when we all the you we all met was we
were on new faces together in Montreal
and I remember Mark uh it was like 2013
or something I remember Mark uh came up
to me he's like there's this guy Rick
Glassman on my show and he's so weird
and great I loved it and I was like oh
cool so Mark was talking up to me and I
was like oh I don't know like and then
you know and then I think we were like
just knew each other I I knew I just
know I mean you're just I see your Clips
all the time I mean for years I I don't
know I remember when you came on I
didn't remember that we met at new faces
yeah but I I thought you didn't know who
I was members I feel bad right I only
remember a few people from our new faces
it was 20 there's 14 20 there's two
shows of 14 right there's 28 people or
something I remember everybody in my
class Pete Davidson Chris D Damien lemon
we had a good we had a good group
um but what you were saying about using
this thing and and heightening it uh I
feel is definitely a big device in
comedy and probably one of the first
ones we learn but it does come from a
place of of of of of of
um uh defense yes and and shame and fear
and you're using it and you're turning
it and that's a great tool yeah but it's
it's to me it's a bit surface and then
once you kind of get what it is and who
you are and and I mean this is corny as
it sounds like truly learn to accept
yourself you're not needing to heighten
those attributes but you're not running
away from them yes it's like the n-word
it hurts it's horrible and it bothers
people but you can spin it and make it
and give you an example well let's see
he only does that off camera his n-words
and there's black people no no and
Edwards have got to go but yeah I don't
even want to talk about pastries well we
gotta rap because we got we got it oh
yeah
but but uh Mark both you guys plug some
stuff yes I you literally was on my
website all right all right I'll be all
over the road uh you know clubbing
coming to clubs Theaters
markdormancomedy.com San Jose New Haven
Toronto Royal Oak Michigan Orlando
uh Iowa City Lincoln Nebraska
Minneapolis Portland Oregon Portland
Maine Seattle Vancouver New Orleans
Boston Philly it sounds like you forgot
the forgot the song the Alabama Alaska
Arizona Arkansas but you did it on order
oh I don't know that song you never
learned that song remember all the
states no no I got them up here uh check
out the Netflix same time tomorrow oh
when does it come out September 1st
that's right around the corner
cat yes spirits.com get on that I'll be
in uh uh Omaha Phoenix Lexington New
Brunswick Oklahoma City Springfield
Missouri Fort Wayne Kansas City Tacoma
Spokane see on the road we might be
drunkpod.com for all the merch beard you
we love you Matt Peters
please I could tell you after or no but
I want keep it wrong because I want this
for my podcast I want to show it hit me
go to this website please taiso tyso
cards c-a-r-d-s.com oh you got your own
playing cards I do I do no I do trading
cards uh Scott heifer an unbelievable
artist click here and I'm making him a
previous guest and I would love to make
you two with your permission and tell me
who you how cool are these whoa It's
like a caricature
is there a Griffith is Mark Maron
there's Blake Griffin that one looks
awesome new ones yeah aren't these
amazing the new ones that just came out
click the Vegas dads it's my family here
we go to Vegas it's um he's uh Mr Potato
Head ah cousin Teddy Dragon Ball Z guys
he's awesome these are so good I mean
this brings me back to my youth that
kind of art
love it
um I'd love to be included in the uh Sam
would you like to be a card I would be
honored who would you be geez it could
be from any any Universe of any uh isn't
that amazing and that's fine yeah he's
unbelievable I I want either Wolverine
or Captain I'm already Wolverine I'll be
Captain America do you see tell me why
you see yourself as a captain right I
just like them always could he be
Captain America before he went goes in
the chamber and get strong
who's a good person for me Spider-Man
yeah because you're yeah Peter Parker
long all right give me Spider-Man who do
you see yourself I want like an old
school Detective Comics Dick Tracy like
Detective Comics that's like actual like
Robin or Batman but that old yellow
background very primary colors you know
what you'd be great yes it's obvious and
it's Detective Comics uh-huh well
technically it wasn't but it's Batman I
would I'll take it no no no not man I'm
saying he's in Batman uh Riddler
Riddler yeah I don't see that I don't
know uh well you're not Joker because
Joker doesn't have jokes around it but
as a comedian all right I don't know I
see you you have his frame you're doing
Little Riddles like remember what you
did about the Uber and it was about DUIs
yeah Ah that's more facts
I don't know you gotta roll because we
gotta we got a friend waiting yes we
love you guys Rick you're amazing guys
this is a great episode thank you for
having me thank you for my last four
minutes of commercials
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
feeling dangerous
[Music]
[Music]